[Music]
this notion fulfilled itself on one side
in the self-assured spirit that acted
and on the other in religion in religion
at one for Consciousness the absolute
content as content or in the form of
picture thinking the form of otherness
for Consciousness on the other hand in
the prior shape the form is that of the
self itself
for it contains the self-assured spirit
that acts the self accomplishes the life
of absolute spirit
this shape is as we have seen that
simple notion which however surrenders
its Eternal Essence it is there in the
real world or it acts the self-sundering
or stepping forth into existence stems
from the purity of the notion for this
is absolute abstraction or negativity
similarly the notion gets the element of
its actuality or the being it contains
in pure knowledge itself for this is
simple immediacy which is as much being
in existence as it is Essence the former
negative thought the latter positive
thought itself
finally this existence both as existence
and as duty is just as much the
reflectedness into self out of pure
knowledge or the state of evil this
withdrawal into itself constitutes the
antithesis of the notion and is thus the
emergence of the pure knowledge of the
essence the knowing that does not act
and is not actual
but this emergence in the antithesis is
participation in it the pure knowledge
of essence has in principle renounced
its simple Unity for it is the
self-sundering or the negativity which
the notion is so far as this
self-sundering is the process of
becoming for itself it is evil so far as
it is the in itself it remains good
now what at first happens in principle
is at the same time explicitly for
Consciousness and is thus double it is
both for Consciousness and also is it's
being for self or its very own Act
the same thing that is already posited
in principle now therefore repeats
itself as Consciousness is knowledge of
it and conscious Act
each in relation to the other let's go
of the independent determinantness with
which it comes forth against it this
letting go is the same renunciation of
the one-sidedness of the notion that in
itself constituted the beginning but it
is now its own Act of renunciation just
as the notion which it renounces is its
own notion
that in itself that is the immediacy of
the beginning is in truth it as
negativity no less mediated what it is
in truth it now also makes it explicit
and the negative is as determinateness
of each both for the other and in itself
self-suspending one of the two parts of
the antithesis is the disparity between
the Notions being within itself in its
individuality and universality the other
the disparity between its abstract
universality and the self
the former dies to its being for self
disowns itself makes confession
the latter renounces the obstinacy of
its abstract universality and in so
doing dies to its lifeless self and to
its unmoved universality
the former has thus completed itself
through the moment of universality which
is Essence and the latter through the
universality which is self
through this movement of action Spirit
has come on the scene as a pure
universality of knowing which is
self-consciousness as self-consciousness
that is the simple Unity of knowing it
is only through action that spirit is in
such a way that it is really there that
is when it raises its existence into
thought and thereby into an absolute
antithesis and returns out of this
antithesis in and through the antithesis
itself
paragraph
796 is quite long and I think our
commentary will have to similarly
extend pretty far I do want to call
attention to two main things before we
get started with a commentary proper one
is that if you actually look at the
German text or you look at some of the
other translations it appears that
Miller somehow ended up transposing to
sentences so where the paragraph ends in
the Miller translation is not really
where it ends in hegel's original or in
you know more recent translations it's
not a big deal because I I think it
doesn't really change the tenor of
what's going on unless you you know are
very
hermeneutically oriented and think that
every single placement matters so much I
think that it's okay but I did want to
signal that just in case anyone is
looking at the German text or looking at
other translations the other thing that
I want to say
is that if you're reading this for the
first or second time you might be
missing out on something that I think is
actually
quite important in this paragraph and
I'm going to hit on this a number of
times
namely that Action Honda
is incredibly important
actuality as it's translated here or
reality vehicle kite is also incredibly
important and that is where Hegel is
going with things absolute knowing makes
it sound as if what we're doing is very
abstract and purely on the speculative
or cognitive side not on the Practical
side and I think one of the great powers
of hegel's phenomenology and his his
philosophy in general is not just you
know let's look at history or we've got
dialectical development or things like
that
it is that Hegel
is constantly trying to show us to bring
us back to the importance of real life
actuality we are spirits the
Consciousness and self-consciousness
developing and this is also spirit and
it develops by doing things by taking
positions I think that all too often
gets left out
in the summaries or presentation or even
sometimes weirdly enough application of
hegel's work so
let's take a look at this there's
there's a lot going on you notice that
we've got kind of like a rotation or
circus
circuit through a whole bunch of
different important transitions he
begins by talking about this notion
fulfilling itself or literally gave
itself Gap right itself fulfillment
how so uh and two sides and we're going
to see a lot of binaries here being
brought together in the the self-assured
spirit that acted right there's that key
theme right there and then in religion
and you know religion was this big
section that we just got through it's
supposed to lead us into absolute
knowing so how does religion work he
said in religion what was the attainment
the achievement of it it won for
Consciousness the absolute good content
in halt as content or if we want to
oppose something to content a form a
form of what picture thinking for
stellen representation right and this
happens as we saw through the community
we don't have to go through all of this
again but it's really interesting here
that he calls picture thinking the form
of otherness for Consciousness why would
picture thinking be the form of
otherness for Consciousness after all
isn't picture thinking if it's thinking
now of course Hagel is not calling
picture thinking thinking that is
Miller's translation but representing
the same thing would hold isn't it a
Consciousness that is doing the
representing yes but the Consciousness
that is religious comes to approach that
you know the narrative or if we want to
think about the absolute religion
Christianity the crucifix right what the
body representing something
um all of this it's approaching it as an
other that it can relate itself to and
there's a danger of as we've seen
falling back into the old form of we saw
this in the self-consciousness section
the unhappy Consciousness where there's
this estrangement this disconnect right
so now he's going to leave religion
behind in this discussion and say okay
what's going on on this other side
self-assured spirit that active
the prior shape of the form that is that
of the self itself prior to what prior
to the religion section right that's how
we wound up finishing spirit and getting
into religion in the first place
so he says it contains the self-assured
spirit
that acts or acted right Honda
the self accomplishes the life of
absolute spirit so this is really quite
interesting and I don't want you to pass
through this too quickly
think about what the implications of
this are
this means that again the
phenomenologies I've pointed out so many
times is not a purely linear process
it's that we go back and forth and back
and forth and we realize that other
stuff back there that we need to bring
forward that's what aofhaben is right
and so the self-assured spirit that
acted is where some really important
stuff was taking place for the
development of Consciousness it
accomplishes the life of absolute spirit
and then he says this shape this Gestalt
is as we have seen that simple notion
which however surrenders its Eternal
Essence right now what is this
surrendering it's
Eternal essence it's no longer remaining
in a sort of abstraction or just pure
representation it's finding stuff out
about itself the world others its
Community right how does it do that it
is there and Miller has bracketed here
in the real world I don't think Miller's
wrong about that right it is there to be
there is to be in some particular
location and how is it there it acts as
Hegel says it does something right and
the actions could be as trivial as
somebody saying prayers or wondering
about their existence and feeling
certain things action doesn't always
have to be some big coordinated plan
but it is getting to know reality
through acting right so this is going to
lead us now to thinking about the simple
notion and he tells us that it's uh
splitting right it's self-sundering and
Zion quite literally uh a twoing of
itself at a distance it is coming apart
you could say he also talks about
stepping forward or stepping into
existence herefore threatened right
stepping out there
um into the world now this is very very
interesting isn't it you almost have
Hegel sounding a little bit like
Heidegger here in his discussion of
dazine don't you or we could talk about
many others as well this is all there in
hegel's phenomenology because this is
part of the way that Hegel
conceptualizes or thinks through what it
is for Speed hear it in human beings to
actually
make sense of the notion or the concept
that the Griff
right
so he says this stems from the purity of
the notion the heinheit right for this
is absolute abstraction or negativity as
of pretty high uh language there
um it's negativity right this is
something that we're quite familiar with
from the preface onward how does
Consciousness self-consciousness Spirit
how does it work by not accepting the
world just as it is or every single
explanation as having been given and
introducing something if not necessarily
new or original something that is in
addition a surplus but the Surplus
always comes out of what is not there
negativity again sounding kind of like
Heidegger right but what we should
really say is that Heidegger sounds a
lot like Hegel since one is coming much
later right
so he goes on and he says similarly the
notion right the simple notion here the
concept the GIF
um gets the element of its actuality
very clear right I just mentioned that
or the being it contains in pure
knowledge itself for this is simple
immediacy and immediacy or in
mitzelbache right and this is going to
come up at several different points
there's no true pure immediacy in
anything that Hegel is going to tell us
about because there's no pure immediacy
in our experience in the reality we
inhabit we can always take what appears
to be immediate I mean think about sense
certainly right the most immediate uh
What suggests itself to us right off the
bat ah we unpack it and there's all
sorts of other things there so
interestingly he's got this phrase in
this pyramidity it's as much being Zine
as existence thozine as Essence vasen
these are all just kind of being thrown
around together and not uh strictly
distinguished from itself and then he
goes on the former negative thought the
latter positive thought itself so
positivity negativity being brought
together here now
we move on through what attending to
existence and again
fascinating isn't it to see what does
our existence really like
are we just these beings that go around
you know uh engaging with the world in
certain ways like we nourish ourselves
we eat a little something over here and
then we run around we look at stuff
our existence
is already one caught up
with moral values
like it or not by virtue of Being Human
normativity in a very broad sense is
part of the
nature the essence the if we want to say
the concept of human being and we
discover this through our
encountering our duties our requirements
the Norms that impose themselves upon us
and trying to act at least in some
respect if not in accordance with them
at least in relation to them and we do
this constantly right so he says this is
just as much the reflectedness into self
out of pure knowledge or the state of
evil and we saw this before right this
has come up several times in the
religion section also in the uh spirit
section when we looked at how it is that
human action works this comes up a
number of times
um evil booze
the the evil and the good are supposed
to be opposites
all right they're supposed to be in a
contradiction or as Miller is going to
translate it here antithesis a gag and
zots but it turns out that they're
for Hegel intimately
interconnected in human consciousness
and in our moral action that we engage
in which is encompassed into religion
through uh you know representation
so he goes on and he says
it's the emergence of the pure knowledge
of the essence right the Vasan the
knowing that does not act and is not
actual now can The Knowing remain like
that no we are the knowers and we act
and we act in actuality in vercuit
so he says this emergence
uh in the antithesis right
um we're going to have this withdrawal
into itself constituting the antithesis
of the notion the gaganzots and is the
emergence of this the emergence in the
antithesis is participation tile Nama
um tile Naman rather in it and
interestingly we're going to see this
term tile come up in uh the distinctions
a little bit later on right so
antithesis
contradiction better
and the
being governed by the contradiction
means engaging in the contradiction
itself
so it's as if the contradiction puts
things into this box over here the evil
box and this box over here the good box
good and evil here
are intimately intertwined and they're
connected up with metaphysical Notions
for Hegel as well as they have been
throughout the phenomenology so he goes
on and he says
the pure knowledge of essence has in
principle right and in principle is
anzik right so we've got anzik and
furzik being used here not just for the
good which is the anzique in itself and
the evil the four itself
those things those categories are also
coming up in their relation to each
other you can look at the opposition
between the anzik the in itself and the
frusic the four itself in an on-seek way
and in a furious way which transforms
into no longer just being through Zeke
but being for all sorts of other things
as well as we're going to see so he
tells us here
um
it is the the self-sundering right it's
renounce the simple Unity it is the
self-sundering once again we see that or
the negativity which the notion is
so far as this self-sundering is the
process of becoming
for itself it is it is evil right so far
as it is the in itself it remains good
and then he says what happens in
principle is at the same time explicitly
for Consciousness and thus
double it can't remain purely in itself
or in principle it can't remain
unmediated it has to be mediated by the
for itself you can't have if we want to
play with words here you can't have a
plain old good simple rendering of the
opposition between Good and Evil
the opposition itself the contradiction
itself has to become transformed and
that is what we see happening as we go
on in this how so what's the double it
is both for consciousness
right for bavus then and is also is it's
being for self or once again key thing
its own act to an an action a thing that
it does uh which comes under handle
action and vehicle-cut actuality
so
what does this lead us to
another transition
each of them let's go what's each of
them good evil or the in principle and
the four Consciousness or the four
Consciousness and the being for self in
its own Act
each of them let's go and this is going
to lead us to the next understanding of
the antithesis
um
let's go of what
independent substandica determiniveness
right
um so the determinedness now where did
we get determinedness in here at all
we're in actuality that's where we're
going to get determinedness right we're
not going to get it in these purely
abstract uh understandings of the notion
so he goes on and he says
um
lets go of the independent
determinantness with which it comes
forth against it and he says this
letting go is this is the same
renunciation of the one-sidedness of the
notion that in itself constituted the
beginning right one-sidedness this is
always a problem
uh we're not going to have absolute
knowing that is merely
one-sided or if we want to pick up on
this we're not going to be able to have
a dynamic way of using our mental
faculties that reduces down to
representation and us being opposed to
it in absolute knowing so going on he
says it's now its own Act of
renunciation and here he's got something
really interesting to say so the notion
which it renounces is its own notion
we cannot remain content with just
sticking with the text we have to think
this out dynamically within I would
hagel's not saying this here but I would
venture to say this and this might be
one way in which we can keep Hegel
relevant
within the scope of our own lives we
have to think this out what is it for me
to have by the time I get to the end of
this book
absolute knowing as the person I am not
your William Friedrich Hegel not some
guy writing this in the early 1800s but
somebody living in the 21st century in
the culture that I inhabit how do I make
this something relevant something
possible for myself that's the notion
that he's talking about here renouncing
its own notion so he goes on and he says
that in itself of the beginning is in
truth
in vahite
as negativity no less mediated
we are fully mediated right we're this
whole process is being mediated by
hegel's text we're mediating it by
thinking it through in our present
circumstance
so he goes on and he says what it is in
truth it now also makes explicit it it
brings it out and the negative is as
determinateness
of each both for the other and in itself
self-suspending what is that going to
look like
here he's going to bring up antithesis
again which again same word gagan's
that's the contradiction
what is the contradiction here what does
it turned into well it's got two parts
two sides to it you know uh the
antithesis of the notion The Living
Concept as we're working it out of the
two parts
um one is the disparity
both of these have a
inequality a not mapping up a not being
commensurate with each other and unlike
height on one side and unglacide on the
other side so the disparity or on
glycoid between once
the Notions being within itself in its
individuality
this is actually one long string of
German terms right being within itself
in its individuality of this notion it's
Enzo and Heights right
um versus
universality alga mine Heights
that's kind of cool here because if you
think about what hagel's doing with
language
universality something nice and simple
right here right and being within itself
in its individuality oh that's
complicated isn't it and these are being
opposed to each other as one side of
this this contradiction what's the other
side of the contradiction right the
disparity the unglig height between its
abstract
universality so at universality here is
not necessarily abstract but now it's
abstract universality versus the self
what it actually is and he goes on and
he says the former dies to its being for
self disowns itself makes confession the
latter renounces the obstinacy of its
abstract universality so the self is
going to become important doing so dies
to its lifeless life itself and to its
unmoved universality right so none of
these are complete except in relation to
each other within this antithesis or
contradiction
and then he tells us
through this movement of action and this
is actually going to be the the end part
um Spirit has come on the scene
as a pure universality of knowing now it
sounds here like hegel's saying all
right we did all the transformational
stuff we needed to do now we get our you
know pure uh knowing no The Knowing is
itself an act of knowing and a knowing
of a being within the world that is
doing things so he goes on uh it is
self-consciousness right and as
self-consciousness that is the simple
Unity of knowing and here we get
something really interesting there's a
transformation of language
happening here that Miller's translation
unfortunately covers up a little bit it
is only through action that spirit is in
such a way that it is really there
actually there that is when it raises
its existence into thought and thereby
into an absolute antithesis now absolute
antithesis here is absolutely and
gigan's not the same same thing as gig
and zots right although you notice
there's a lot of similarity there but
this is uh the ant has a sort of spatial
quality to it it is pulling these things
apart as we saw before right
um and Zion right
um so is this you know absolutely a
distinction between contradiction and
opposition as is often translated no but
it is important and it returns out of
this antithesis in and through the
antithesis itself now hegel's not using
the term three times he's just using
sort of referential language here but
that's that's what it is engaged in so
what can we say to sum this up with all
of these interesting Transformations
going on
we come back again to the importance of
action and being in a world being within
actuality or reality we can talk as much
as we want about Pure or absolute
knowing but that is going to be absolute
knowing that understands itself within a
context cultural context a context of
other people's lives of one's own life
that's I think what we need to be
reading in here in order to continue
this Advance through this thing that
Hegel is calling absolute knowing